bonsoir à toutes et à tous bonsoir
monsieur jancovici on se retrouve donc
ce soir pour le troisième épisode de
penser l'après série de webinaires qui
invite les acteurs du changement dans
votre salon l'idée de cette série c'est
de pouvoir imaginer penser mais surtout
anticiper ce que sera la situation après
le corps energy inc
c'est une situation qui va être
compliqué qui est assez floue
aujourd'hui à montquiers on s'est
retrouvé en compagnie de jean jouzel qui
est climatologue
on a pu parler de la thématique
politique basque
aujourd'hui on se retrouve donc à
monsieur jean comme ici pour parler
d'une thématique assez proche mais un
peu différente qui sont les politiques
énergétiques
quand vous connais assez bien dans le
milieu vous avez dans des acteurs les
plus impliqués sur la question de
transition énergétique et vous soumettez
donc régulièrement des propositions
allant dans ce sens sur vos réseaux
sociaux et notamment par le biais des
sociétés et des entreprises dans
lesquelles vous travaillez vous est
surtout reconnue non comme l'un des
acteurs en fait qui rend surtout le plus
accessible en fait savoir un
scientifique notamment dans vos posts
quotidien donc sur les réseaux sociaux
alors je vous remercie vraiment d'avoir
accepté cette invitation et de venir
partager avec nous votre vision et votre
compréhension des événements aujourd'hui
pour cela mon cul comme guerre comme
mardi on va procéder avec 45 minutes des
changes sur la base de questions que
j'ai presque j'ai préparé précédemment
et ensuite on va réaliser un échange de
30 minutes environ avec les participants
je vais donc dès maintenant à poser vos
questions en anglais questions-réponses
juste en bas et puis vous pouvez
également voter pour les questions que
vous trouvez les plus pertinentes mais
commencez à vous présenter monsieur
jancovici
je laisse les parents voulaient savoir
quoi ce que je fais oui et non la vie de
tous les jours qui vous êtes d'où vous
venez
alors en ce moment les courses et la
vaisselle mais sinon quand on n'est pas
confiné donc j'ai trois activités
essentielles on va dire
la première c'est que je suis associé
d'une société où faut maintenant un
petit groupe de sociétés qui s'appelle
44 et dont la vocation est d'essayer de
travailler pour les acteurs économiques
pour les aider à progresser sur la prise
en compte des contraintes énergie climat
dans leurs activités
ma deuxième activité c'est d'avoir créé
il ya maintenant une dizaine d'années
une association qui s'appelle de shit
project
qui est ce que les anglo-saxons
appellent un think tank et qui essaye de
faire des changes et des propositions
sur la bonne manière de décarboniser
l'économie et enfin j'ai une troisième
activité dans laquelle je mets
l'enseignement les conférences un bref
tout ce qui est de la vulgarisation ou
de la passation de savoir où j'ai envie
de dire le l'élément le plus récurrent
c'est que je suis prof à l'école des
mines de paris enfin qui s'appelle
maintenant mines paristech
j'ai également une casquette qui est
d'être membre du conseil pour le climat
est donc tout ce que je vais raconter à
partir de maintenant je n'engage jamais
aucune des entités d'appartenance de
façon directe
même si évidemment je suis complètement
détachée de celle que je pilote en
direct donc voilà à peu près ce que je
fais dans la vie c'est bon je vous
remercie pour cette présentation avec
notamment des carbone carbone 4 on
connaît très bien on nous présente
souvent d'ailleurs dans les cours à
sciences po on nous présente pour
rapport qui aujourd'hui permettent
d'avoir une vision un peu plus pierre
sur tout ce qui se passe en énergie
apparemment même le gouvernement a
parfois du mal à s'y retrouver
je vais bien commencer par les questions
que j'avais préparé dans l'un de vos
posts vous dites il faut aussi se sortir
de l'idée que c'est une crise ce n'est
pas une crise c'est une marche
d'escalier dans une évolution qui en
comportera d'autres c'est une autre
manière de dire que le système n'est pas
durable est ce qu'on doit en conclure
qu'un retour aux systèmes et aux modèles
concrètement d'avant des plus possible
oui on doit en conclure ça alors ce qui
a fait l'essor de la civilisation
industrielle et ce qui a fait de la
possibilité de faire des études longues
par exemple à sciences po de prendre sa
retraite
par exemple dans un ehpad mais pas que
la possibilité de travailler moins
simplement 35 heures par semaine la
possibilité de vivre en ville où nous
n'avons pas d'activités productives
direct c'est par là qu'on fait pousser
natori tueur et c'est pas là que les
ressources pour fabriquer nos vêtements
ou les objets qu'on utilise
toute cette organisation économique et
spatiale de nos activités on le doit à
un élément majeur qui est la hausse de
l'approvisionnement énergétique c'est à
dire la hausse du parc de machines en
fonctionnement parce qu'en fait
l'énergie si on est très sympathique
c'est des croquettes pour machines c'est
parce qu'il permet de mettre en route un
parc d'esclaves énergétique qui
travaillent pour lui cet accroissement
énergétique malheureusement pour nous il
est basé sur une ressource qui a deux
caractéristiques elle est épuisable
c'est anciennement des combustibles
fossiles donc cédé mcdc des combustibles
qui se sont formés par lente
décomposition dans la croûte terrestre
ou parlantes cuisson dans la croûte
terrestre plus exactement de restes de
vie ancienne qui ont vécu n'importe
quand entre il ya 5 millions il ya cinq
cent millions d'années donc ces
combustibles de sont épuisables et par
ailleurs quand on s'en sert on met le
sous produit de leur utilisation qui
s'appelle du gaz carbonique dans
l'atmosphère où il n'a pas de processus
qu'ils enlèvent rapidement rempli la
baignoire et du gaz carbonique et puis
n'est-ce carbonique s'en va pas
facilement de la belle sandra mais pas
facilement le fait qu' on est bâti toute
cette organisation sur des combustibles
fossiles
même en france qui est un pays où on a
l'habitude de penser qu'il ya que
l'énergie nucléaire en fait pas du tout
quand on regarde l'énergie qui alimente
les machines dont on se sert tous les
jours
aspirateur les voitures les industries
etc en fait les deux tiers de l'énergie
qu'on utilise en france proviennent du
pétrole donc les deux tiers de l'énergie
qui alimente nos machines c'est du
pétrole
enfin des dérivés du pétrole et donc le
les pays du monde est monde dans son
ensemble a prospéré sur l'accroissement
de la combe us de la consommation
d'énergie fossile et comme ces énergies
sont épuisables
il ya malheureusement quelque chose qui
dit qu' on ne peut pas avoir un
approvisionnement perpétuellement
croissant ni même perpétuellement
constant avec ces énergies qui sont
épuisables
ce que nous avons vécu en 74
vous vous étiez pas des mois à peine
mais en 1974 il ya déjà eu un premier
craquement dans le système acquis et que
le pétrole qui augmentent et très très
vite c'est lui a augmenté beaucoup moins
liquides en 2005 il ya eu un deuxième
craquement dans le système est en fait
en 2018
on était en train de préparer un
troisième craquement dans le système qui
est que la production mondiale de
pétrole
vraisemblablement passer par un maximum
en 2018 hélas la crise du coc vide en
fait est une crise qui est à une
régulation involontaire d'un système qui
doit se réguler et de toute façon parce
que dire qu'un le système n'est pas
durable c'est dire qu'il ne va pas durer
alors après dire quel est l'événement
qui va faire qu'il va s'arrêter de
fonctionner comme avant ça il faut une
grosse boule de cristal pour y arriver
par contre ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
quand on a un craquement dans un système
qui n'est pas durable en général le
système ne se reconfigure pas après
comme il était avant donc la crise du
coc vide elle va notamment avoir un
effet sur l'approvisionnement pétrolier
qui est très structurant dans le monde
qui nous entoure
c'est que comme il fait baisser le prix
du bail de bain comme cet épisode fait
baisser le prix du baril de pétrole
du coup les pétroliers qui était déjà en
train d'investir massivement pour
essayer de maintenir la production au
niveau auquel elle était vont arrêter
d'investir notamment tous les pétroles
moderne qui permettait à la production
d'augmenter le pétrole de schiste aux
états unis les sables bitumineux au
canada qui sont par ailleurs les
pétroles des plus sales pour
l'environnement c'est ce qui nécessite
le plus d'espacé plus de moyens et bien
là les investissements dans ces types de
productions l'avons beaucoup décélérer
et du coup la quantité totale de pétrole
qu'on va avoir à notre disposition va
baisser alors les gens qui aiment bien
climat diront c'est une excellente
nouvelle
les gens qui aiment bien les codes un
vigneron c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle parce que ça va empêcher
l'économie de redémarrer comme avant
parce que nous allons nous heurter
quelque part au plafond de la quantité
totale de pétrole disponible
par ailleurs il ya des mécanismes j'ai
envie de dire culturel qui n'attendaient
qu'une crise de cette nature pour
s'exprimer
ça fait maintenant des années que vous
avez un certain nombre de gens qui ont
envie d'avoir un système - mondialisé et
plus recentrée sur les états donc le on
a par exemple assister au moment de cet
épisode à quelque chose qu'on ne pensait
pas possible qu'ils aient la fermeture
de frontières intra-européennes donc et
tout ça correspond à des tentations qui
étaient là bien avant la crise ducobu
simplement la clé du coc vie de leur
permet de s'exprimer tout d'un coup et
il est vraisemblable que une partie de
ces expressions sont pas réversible
et ça c'était lié à la mondialisation
qui avait fait pousser des boutons un
certain nombre de gens donc oui il va y
avoir des choses qu'ils ne pourront pas
revenir comme elle était avant par un
mélange d'impossibilité physique est un
mélange de réticences culturelles qui
font alors un truc aussi bête que de se
faire la bise par exemple peut-être que
ça va être très très longtemps avant de
revenir parce que les gens regardent et
faire la bise il avait assassiné il
maladie quelconque
donc il ya voilà il ya des choses qui
vont être pour ça en l'occurrence ça
n'empêchera pas l'économie de tourner
mais il ya un certain nombre d'autres
mécanismes qui vont probablement
s'appliquer de façon significative
dernière chose qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que une crise a un
début et une fin normalement là on sait
quand elle débute en ce qui concerne le
coc vide la faim moi je ne sais pas
l'économie est en train de perdre trois
points de pib par mois quand on va
sortir des deux mois qui deux mois de
confinement
on va sortir avec quelques millions de
chômeurs supplémentaires je sais pas
vous dire si on va en avoir 2 4 ou 6 en
plus mais enfin ça va être le bonheur de
grandeur parce que tous les gens qui
travaillent dans la restauration dans
une partie du commerce dans une partie
de l'industrie dans une partie des parcs
de loisirs dans l'événementiel etc vous
avez plein de gens qui vont se taire et
l'histoire nous enseigne ça vous devez
savoir à sciences po que quand on a une
grosse grosse crise économique comme ça
et que derrière il n'y a pas de reprise
rapide parce que le pétrole nous
empêchera d'avoir une reprise rapide et
bien en général ça sent pas très bon il
ya un certain nombre de cas de figures
de l'histoire ça c'est vraiment très mal
terminé donc je serais tu fais partie
des gens qui disent faut être très
vigilant sur ce qui va se passer dans
les mois à venir
parce qu'on pourrait très bien se
préparer des épisodes encore beaucoup
moins drôle que ce qu'on est en train de
vivre en ce moment donc pour rebondir un
peu sur ce que vous venez de dire si je
comprends bien on est passé d'un modèle
où on pensait pouvoir et tirer un peu à
l'infini nos ressources et notre
capacité à accroître toujours plus à un
modèle qui se retrouve finalement limité
par ses ressources physiques en quelque
sorte
redécouvre le fait que les ressources
physiques sont limitantes pour
l'économie malheureusement c'est quelque
chose qui n'a pas été prises en compte
au moment où on a théorisé l'économie
classique qui vous sert à avoir de très
beaux cours d'économie à sciences po
alors je vais vous faire une confidence
quand j'étais jeune j'ai eu moi aussi
des cours d'économie
il ya une partie de mes cours d'économie
auquel je ne comprenais strictement rien
et alors je me disais c'est que je dois
une bête si je comprends bien et j'ai il
y avait aussi des trucs et je n'arrivais
pas à comprendre dans la presse et
j'éviterai très longtemps à comprendre
qu'en fait je ne comprenais rien tout
simplement parce que la théorie était
totalement bancale on essayait de
justifier avec des trucs qui sont
dollars de la religion des processus
observable dans le monde avec des
théories qui colle pas du tout et j'ai
fini par comprendre que la raison pour
laquelle on n'arrive pas à l'expliquer
c'est que la théorie et la base est
mauvaise alors qu'est ce qui est mauvais
dans la théorie c'est que pour faire une
fourchette
vous avez assurément besoin d'un
banquier sympathique pour faire une
usine de fourchette
enfin pour vous prêter pour faire vous
avez assurément besoin d'ouvriers pour
travailler dans votre signe de son chef
mais vous avez aussi besoin de minerai
de fer et le charbon sinon vous faites
pas l'acier avec lequel vous faites pas
la fourchette ou ça serait pareil si la
fourchette était en plastique jetables
ce qui est une horreur absolue
eh bien on voit bien que pour faire un
objet vous avez besoin d'une ressource
et même pour faire un service vous avez
besoin d'une ressource le webinaire en
est en train de faire en ce moment il a
besoin de ressources parce que s'il n'y
avait pas les câbles en cuivre et la
fibre optique qui permettent aussi
lialda les depuis chez moi jusque depuis
tous les gens qui nous écoutent n'y
aurait pas de webinaires et s'il n'y
avait pas les mines pour faire
l'ordinateur quand je suis en train de
me servir
il n'y aurait pas l'ordinateur devrait
pas tous évidemment on voit bien même
les services ont besoin conscience et
ses ressources n'ont jamais été prises
en compte dans la théorie économique
la théorie économique elle a dit la
seule chose qui compte pour avoir de la
production économique c'est le travail
humain c'est le facteur humain c'est le
travail humain et c'est les rangs du
maine au capital et à partir du moment
où on ne met que deux facteurs dans la
production économique qui eux mêmes
n'ont pas de limites apparentes puisque
du capital
il suffit de faire la création monétaire
vous avez autant de rouler et des
travailleurs il suffit de se reproduire
comme des lapins et vous en avez autant
que vous voulez donc il n'y a pas de
sujet c'est-à-dire croissant et
multiplions et une production économique
qui croîtra
donc avec ce genre de théorie on pense
que la production économique peut
augmenter sans limite est du reste nulle
part dans l'économie qu'on vous a
enseigné à l'école
vous n'avez quelqu'un qui vous a fait la
démonstration que à partir de cent mille
milliards 352 millions 725 dollars de
pib ça s'arrête pas une démonstration
qui conduisent à ça d'accord on est on
s'est nourri d'une illusion qui est que
la croissance peut être perpétuel et
sauf que les lois de la physique qui
sont plus fortes que nous nous ont
rattrapés disant non c'est pas vrai ça
marchait pas aussi simplement que ça
alors les rattrapages se fait en
plusieurs temps ce pour ça que j'ai
utilisé l'expression de la marche
d'escalier
il ya eu un premier rattrapage à la fin
des trente glorieuses au moment des
chocs pétroliers où on a eu une première
marche d'escalier qu'on a descendu qui
était la croissance était très rapide
elle est devenu beaucoup moins rapide on
a eu une deuxième marche d'escalier
qu'on a descendu à partir de 2005 qui a
conduit à la crise des subprimes et qui
est en fait une crise énergétique aux
financières
le premier déterminant a été une
décélération économique lié à un
problème énergétique et là on était au
début du franchissement d'une troisième
marche d'escalier donc le coville n'a
fait qu'accélérer mais s'il n'y avait
pas eu de kobe dont il aurait franchi
quand même qui est que depuis 2018 donc
je le disais la production de pétrole
était probablement passé par un maximum
historique en tout cas si c'était pas
2018 c'était dans pas longtemps donc
s'apprêtait d'édifices s'apprêtait elle
a au dessus à craquer un grand coup
et j'en veux pour preuve que le commerce
mondial par exemple avait commencé à
baisser depuis 2018 ils étaient orientés
à la baisse que la production
industrielle dans les pays ocde et
commencé à baisser depuis novembre 2018
donc vous avez on a vu apparaître dans
la sphère financière tout un tas de
trucs bizarroïde des taux négatifs qui
se multiplient et c'est donc on voit
bien vous voyez bien que le système
était tectonique des plaques étaient en
train de nous le met en tension là d'une
manière pas sympathique et le cockpit
n'a fait qu'accélérer donc c'est un
élément conjoncturel c'est le petit
grain de sable qui a fait cristallisé
tout le système est qu'il ya qui a fait
un peu craqué tout le système
les économistes encore une fois ne
voyant pas la question de la ressource
ils se disent bas de 20 ses parts à voir
partir comme hier donc on va de nouveau
repartir de l'avant et là
malheureusement c'est pas ça qui va se
passer
alors c'est très ennuyeux parce que ça
induit dans l'opinion le sentiment
d'être trahie et trahi pardon et tromper
parce que le discours dominant est en
fait pas confiance la croissance va
revenir alors que ça ne dépend pas des
élus mais ça dépend de la physique crée
derrière ce sentiment d'injustice qui
est on nous a raconté des salades et on
nous a dit qu'on allait pouvoir remettre
en place le système comme avant alors
que malheureusement ça n'est pas le cas
et pour finir là-dessus je pense que
malheureusement le grand défi qui attend
qui nous attend pour l'avenir
je suis désolé de dire ça à votre
génération parce que c'est aussi celle
de mes enfants
le grand défi qui nous attend pour
l'avenir et celui d'arriver à être
heureux dans un monde sans croissance
ce qu'il est renversant par rapport aux
réflexes culturels que nous avons été
présents dans un monde sans croissance
l'augmentation à l'ancienneté ça pose
problème
il exhorte le permis dont on a un beau
futur aux prévisions pour rebondir un
peu sur un élément que vous avez
mentionné précédemment qui est la baisse
du prix du pétrole puisque on sait
aujourd'hui que le baril se trouve à peu
près autour de 25 $ si je me trompe pas
notamment aussi avec le gaz de schiste
qui va être encore plus impactés par
cette crise a est ce que ça va entraîner
des chocs au niveau des investissements
sur les énergies renouvelables ou parce
que ça ne va pas du tout alors le bas
prix du pétrole va avoir plusieurs
conséquences
la première c'est que dès que l'occasion
s'en présentera on aura envie de se
remettre en consommer plus jusqu'au
moment où on va taper sur la production
qui est orienté à la baisse et à ce
moment en aura de nouveau un choc à très
court terme ça va un peu dissuader les
investissements dans les énergies
renouvelables ce qui l'a surtout
dissuader les investissements dans les
énergies renouvelables c'est qu'il faut
pas oublier que ces investissements sont
aidés par des mécanismes de subvention
et que quand on est en situation de
disette les mécanismes de subventions on
a on a envie de les regarder d'un peu
plus près
surtout qu'un certain nombre de gens
comme moi considère que les énergies
renouvelables qu'on est en train d'aider
en ce moment en france sont pas les
bonnes
qu'il faudrait s'occuper de celle qui
substitue de la chaleur et des produits
pétroliers est pas celle qui substitue
l'électricité et qui est essentiellement
nucléaire tombe décarbonés
indépendamment ce qu'on peut reprocher
au nucléaire alors c'est pas vrai dans
d'autres pays évidemment donc il ya des
pays où c'est très utile de faire des
énergies renouvelables électriques si on
en fait en pologne c'est une très bonne
idée mais effectivement dans ces pays là
ça va être un peu probablement un peu un
peu calmé je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose qui est encore plus ennuyeux mais
ça va pas durer très longtemps encore
une fois je pense que dès qu'on veut on
voudra faire repartir l'économie à
l'identique le pétrole va se remettre à
bondir vers des sommets si frileux
prennent cette fois les venues très
volatil ces derniers temps donc le pas
prix du pétrole peut très bien ne pas
durer très longtemps si je peux me
permettre de vous couper 1 vous avez
mentionné justement des énergies
renouvelables qui pourraient se
substituer à l énergie thermique qui
réalise avec le pétrole à quelle énergie
est ce que vous pensez
mais sur la thermique par exemple nom
alors je pense à la pompe à chaleur qui
permet de supprimer le chauffage au
fioul et au gaz donc une pompe à chaleur
c'est un frigo à verser à vous si vous
avez un frigo dans votre cuisine vous
savez qu'à l'intérieur il fait froid
normalement et si vous allez passer
votre main derrière le frigo il fait
chaud donc en fait là le frigo est une
machine à extraire les calories de
l'intérieur du frigo et à les rejeter à
l'extérieur dans la pièce est bien une
pompe à chaleur c'est la même chose
c'est un frigo qui est ouvert sur
l'extérieur
donc il va extraire les calories de
l'extérieur ils les rejettent dans votre
logement et il se trouve que ce
processus là la physique le permet
utilise beaucoup moins d'énergie que la
quantité totale d'énergie transférer si
vous regardez l'énergie qui est
transféré depuis l'extérieur vers
l'intérieur de chez vous c'est beaucoup
moins d'énergie que l'énergie utilisée
pour faire tourner la pompe à chaleur
donc il ya un coefficient multiplicateur
alors qui est pas de la magie c'est
juste que ça transfert d'énergie d'un
côté à l'autre du mur de la maison qui
permet à ce dispositif d'être assez
efficace et par ailleurs il fonctionne à
l'électricité qui doit de payer
décarbonée si vous remplacez et les
compare à chaleur sont comptés comme
énergie renouvelable dans l'inventaire
national français et il faut savoir que
dès à présent
la quantité d'énergie renouvelable
chaleur renouvelable transférer parce
que c'est la chaleur du sol l'air
transféré par les pompes à chaleur c'est
aussi important que l'éolien pays mais
ça coûte beaucoup moins cher aux
contribuables et donc ça permet de
remplacer du chauffage au fuel qui lui
dépend d'importations de pétrole émet du
co2 et de chauffage au gaz qui dépend
d'importations de gaz et qui émet du co2
donc ça c'est la première énergie
renouvelable à laquelle on peut penser
la deuxième c'est le bois dans le bois
peut être utilisé pour des réseaux de
chaleur il peut être utilisé pour la
chaleur industrielle dans les pays très
boisé par exemple l'autriche a pas mal
d'industrie qui tourne au bois la suède
a énormément d'industrie qui tourne au
bois et enfin vous pouvez utiliser
également la biomasse pour faire du
biogaz qui peut être injecté dans le
réseau eau pour les usages du gaz ou qui
peut servir pour du machinisme agricole
avec des moteurs à gaz ou des camions
par exemple et enfin vous pouvez
également faire des agrocarburants mais
les agrocarburants c'est pas la manière
la plus efficace de se passer de pétrole
aujourd'hui il vaut beaucoup mieux
diminuer la taille des voitures dans un
premier temps est resté au pétrole ça
permettra d'économiser beaucoup plus de
pétrole que de garder les même taille
des voitures est maître des arts au
carburant c'est mieux de regarder deux
chevaux et enfin
donc voilà l'essentiel des énergies
renouvelables auxquelles jeu auquel je
pensais quand je pensais à celles qui
peuvent substituer des produits
pétroliers et gaziers
si aujourd'hui voilà je reviens à mon
pétrole donc la baisse du prix du
pétrole a effectivement une incidence
sur les énergies renouvelables au sens
de ça incite les gens à s'en détourner
mais comme je le disais depuis qu'on a
passé le pic du pétrole conventionnel
dans le monde c'est-à-dire 2008 le prix
du pétrole est devenu extrêmement
volatile même vous vous en souvenez
peut-être donc entre 2005 et 2008 ça a
explosé après en 2009 ça s'est cassé la
gueule en 2010 à 2014 sahara eux explosé
puis en 2015
redescendu maintenant le prix du pétrole
fait le yoyo à relativement brève
échéance
ce qui est un problème supplémentaire
parce que si vous vous caler sur le prix
du pétrole en dicter votre politique
énergétique vous avez un signal aussi y
en qui nous trouble de la vue et donc ça
ne remplace pas une volonté politique
sur le long terme de dire on va faire ça
après le il ya un autre gros problème
sur la baisse du prix du pétrole lui qui
est à mon avis un problème majeur on
parle assez peu c'est que ça va créer un
désordre budgétaire très important chez
les exportateurs de pétrole
vous avez énormément de pays dans le
monde enfin et non mais vous avez un
certain nombre de pays dans le monde qui
sont cuits ciellement dépendant des
exportations de pétrole et de gaz
et on en a un pas très loin d'une autre
s'appelle d'algérie à thierry bonne
partie de l'économie du pays repose
là-dessus et c'est là que c'est grâce à
ça que les gens mangent pas ce que c'est
avec les exportations de pétrole et gaz
qu'ils importent la nourriture qui
pousse pas chez eux et qu'ils arrivent à
nourrir la population
si le prix des hydrocarbures restent bas
pendant longtemps surtout si dans le
même temps le prix de la nourriture
explose captiva être le cas parce qu'une
partie des exploitations agricoles vont
souffrir à cause du confinement parce
que canicule deux années de suite et que
si ça se trouve on va encore s'en
prendre 8 cette année
il suffit à ce moment qu'il ya un effet
de ciseaux entre des exportations
d'hydrocarbures qui sont basses parce
que le prix du pétrole est bas et des
importations alimentaires qui sont
hautes à cause des problèmes que je
viens d'évoquer
et vous aurez la réédition de 2011 qui
ont été des émeutes de la faim dans le
maghreb et déstabilisation politique
derrière qui peuvent être significatives
donc on a ce qu'on a cette bombe à
retardement j'ai envie de dire
[Musique]
jerry vous l'avez également alors au
venezuela il a déjà pété vous l'avez
dans d'autres pays notamment des pays du
golfe ou un jour des problèmes et enfin
vous l'avez en russie en russie un tiers
du pib repose sur les hydrocarbures
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
absolument crucial pour le pays aussi
qui lutte actuellement un peu contre
l'arabie saoudite aussi pour avoir un
peu de temps à la baisse justement sur
le prix du pétrole sont un peu une
guerre géopolitique ou est-ce que ça va
vous des muscles alors ce qu'ils ont le
pari qu'ont fait les saoudiens et les
russes c'est que en maintenant un prix
du pétrole bas il arriverait à avoir la
peau des producteurs de pétrole de
schiste aux états unis parce qu'il se
trouve que les producteurs de pétrole de
schiste aux états unis ont un prix de
revient pour le baril qui se promènent
quelque part entre 40 et 80 dollars le
baril donc les ils sont tous endettés
jusqu'au cou en plus donc ils ont non
seulement le prix du baril doit être
élevée pour qu'ils arrivent à gagner de
l'argent en exploitation mais en plus
ils doivent gagner encore plus d'argent
que ça parce qu'il faut qu'il rembourse
la dette avec les intérêts qu'ils
avaient contracté pour exploiter le
pétrole de schiste
à une époque où le pétrole n'était plus
cher qu'aujourd'hui sur le marché mais
il n'y a pas d'argent quand même donc ce
qui se passe c'est que avec un baril à
20 ou 30 $ vous vous dites les
producteurs de pétrole de schiste sont
tous faillite
donc ils sortent du marché et à ce
moment le pétrole retrouve des niveaux
de prix élevés et en plus j'ai pas la
concurrence de ces gens là voilà donc
c'est ça le pari que les saoudiens et
les russes ont fait les saoudiens
viennent d'être rappelés à l'ordre par
les américains et les systèmes chacun
tient par la barbichette et les russes
du coup ce sont des gens ont changé
d'avis mais c'est mais alors c'est une
guerre à mon avis qu'il ne pouvait pas
gagner
parce que aux états unis le pétrole est
un enjeu tellement stratégique que je
pense que les producteurs de chez lui il
aurait de toute façon été soutenu
directement ou indirectement par la
puissance publique au sens de et durée
sur un gros producteur de chez lloyd qui
vient de passer un chapitre 11 c'est à
dire l'équivalent du régime des
faillites aux états unis et qui a dit il
n'y a pas de problème je continue ma
production est en fait c'est exactement
ça qu'il va se passer si le prix du
pétrole est trop basse et comme le
pétrole etc stratégique pour les
etats-unis c'est les banquiers les
actionnaires qui vont s'asseoir sur sur
leurs actions et sur leur dette
ça n'empêchera pas du tout les
producteurs de pétrole de continuer à
produire c'est important donc on parle
de soutien justement les cas à mode
économique qui n'est plus viable à un
secteur d'activité qui apparemment
consignes produire alors qu'ils ne se
porte pas bien
aujourd'hui on a à peu près le même cas
qui se posent en france avec le secteur
de l'aviation
est-ce que vous pensez que l'état
français doit encore porter secours à ce
secteur
aujourd'hui c'est encore un cédant coup
alors c'est normal
à très court terme pour une raison assez
simple vous vous avez la chance de ne
pas encore avoir besoin d'avoir un
travail pour gagner votre vie il se
trouve que c'est pas capable c'est pas
méchant c'est champagne h
il se trouve que c'est pâques à tout le
monde et que la première tétanie du
gouvernement dans la situation actuelle
ça va être d'essayer de maintenir
l'hémorragie au niveau de l'emploi la
meilleure manière de faire en sorte que
les gens gardent un emploi ou retrouver
un emploi après la crise c'est de leur
faire faire ce qu'ils savent déjà faire
parce que c'est comme ça que vous les
mettez le plus vite possible au travail
donc toutes les sociétés qui sont en
difficulté aujourd'hui le premier souci
du gouvernement ça va être de l'ordre de
leur permettre de retrouver de
l'activité à l'identique
parce que c'est comme ça que vous
remettez les gens au travail de manière
un peu facile si vous dites le transport
aérien j'en ai pas besoin et j'ai besoin
de plus de trains demain matin vous avez
pas les voies ferrées pour faire
circuler les trains nécessairement vous
n'avez pas nécessairement les trains
pour circuler et quelqu'un qui est
personnel navigant sur un avion
alors si vous êtes si vous servez des
repas dans un avion vous n'êtes pas
reconverti en tant que tel dans un frein
parce que dans un train personne ne
servirent pas éventuellement voilà
comprenez c'est donc la possibilité de
reconvertir très près de délais des gens
qui faisait un métier pour leur faire
faire autre chose c'est pas toujours
extrêmement simple et si vous voulez
remplacer les travailleurs immigrés qui
vont ramasser les cerises avec des gens
du secteur aérien alors pour le coup
c'est vraiment compliqué c'est pas
vraiment les mêmes salaires donc le donc
ce qui se passe c'est que le
gouvernement a toujours tendance à
essayer d'aider les activités telle
cette compte telles qu'elles sont
configurés ce cas mon avis le
gouvernement peut faire de mieux et ce
qu'il devrait faire
est ce qu'au chiffre project on va
essayer de formuler c'est qu'on va faire
des propositions en ce sens c'est de
demander des contreparties aux gens que
vous aider donc le transport aérien ok
on le sauve à bref délai parce que
l'idée car français au tapis
c'est quelque chose qui est ennuyeux et
puis l'idée que les gens qui travaillent
soient tous privés d'emploi c'est
quelque chose qui est ennuyeux mais par
contre au moment où vous leur temps des
labos de sauvetage
vous leur dites attention c'est at elle
est allée telles conditions
alors les conditions ça peut être par
exemple que vous allez enlever
durablement 5 ou 10% des avions du
service c'est très exactement ce qu'a
décidé lufthansa lufthansa a décidé de
retirer un certain nombre d'airbus du
service dont des a380 est à mon avis ils
vont pas les remettre en service de
sitôt alors ça pose un problème de
reconversion pour une partie du
personnel
mais c'est pas comme si vous en voyez la
société au tapis vous pouvez à cette
occasion dire comme ça faisait longtemps
les cocos que je voulais vous imposer
une taxe de ceux-ci taxes d'aéroport
proportionnelle à la longueur du voyage
acheté des avions qui consomment moins
voilà vous allez signer avec votre sang
au moment où vous recevez de chaque vous
allez faire ça me promettre de faire
tout de suite
donc c'est ça que le gouvernement
pourrait faire alors il ne le fera pas
de lui-même pour une deuxième raison
c'est que quand vous êtes pompiers
appelés sur un incendie vous appliquer
les consignes que vous avez répété 50
fois avant l'incendié et pendant l'
incendie vous inventez rien et donc là
le gouvernement étant totalement pris au
dépourvu par une crise qu'il n'a pas vu
venir et pour lequel il n'a pas de plan
b c'est à dire qu'à aucun moment dans
les cartons de bercy est dans les
cartons du ministère de transport on a
réfléchi à ce qu'on faisait si air
france avec 90 % de ces avions cloués au
sol
et si derrière il fallait faire repartir
l'activité en enlevant 10 ou 20%
personne n'a jamais réfléchi à ce
problème
donc au moment où vous tendait le cheikh
al air france vous pouvez pas lui dire
voilà les contreparties qu'on demande
puisque personne n'y a réfléchi et dans
le feu de l'action
en ce moment je pense que premier
ministre dans trois heures par nuit donc
c'est évident qu'il n'a pas le temps
réfléchir à ce que il peut demander
comme contrepartie donc comme nous
sommes de bons citoyens o'shea project
on va réfléchir pour lui on a essayé de
reproduire quelques unes mais il faut
bien voir que toute la difficulté de la
situation qu'on va vivre à partir de
maintenant c'est que pour reprendre une
petite formule que j'ai déjà utilisé
c'est pas dans l'urgence que vous faites
le plan d'urgence
donc si vous n'y avez pas pensé avant
vous êtes coincé
et justement sur ces contreparties
j'ai pu lire que la nuit sur la
transition écologique et environnemental
a justement proposé pour la france est
en quelque sorte ses contreparties
elle a été assez vague pour nous donner
un peu des précisions sur une rumeur qui
pourrait être mise en place
alors moi je suis pas dans sa cervelle
donc je ne sais pas ce que c'est joli
c'est normal qu'elles soient vagues
puisque personne ya réfléchi on en
revient à la question tout à l'heure sur
la croissance comme on était dans un
délit de décroissance si je peux dire
c'est à dire au sens d'où on se dise
c'est pas possible donc on va juste pas
y réfléchir et bien strictement rien des
prêts pour l'éventualité où ça se
produise
j'ai aussi bête que ce à quoi je vais
prendre un autre exemple il arrive que
dans notre pays déjà en perdre une jambe
voilà c'est pas drôle vous n'avez pas
envie d'en perdre une moi non plus mais
de temps en temps ça arrive alors comme
c'est déjà arrivé
by la société est organisée pour serra
donc à des fabricants de prothèses de
fauteuils roulants etc
c'est pas drôle mais au moins on a une
solution de repli là on a zéro solution
de repli parce que c'est tellement pas
drôle que personne n'y a pensé
donc on ne sait même pas quoi faire
alors quelques idées contrepartie pour
un air france je vais pas vous dévoiler
ce qu'on va sortir au chic project dans
quinze jours donc je vais vous donner
des exemples le pays pour faire le
gouvernement pourrait dire je vous aide
je vous somme mais je vous préviens que
demain matin on met une taxe d'aéroport
qui est proportionnelle à la longueur du
trajet pour tous les gens qui embarquent
ou débarquent d'accord puisqu'on peut
pas faire de taxation sur le carburant
aérien parce qu' il faudrait un accord
mondial
patati chiffon là on peut très bien en
ce qui concerne les aéroports qui sont
chez nous mettre en place une taxe et à
partir du moment où les gens volent loin
on les taxe beaucoup et ça du coup sa
frêle de transport et alain on pourrait
très bien dire vous avez l'obligation
messieurs d'air france puisque la
l'ouverture du ferroviaire va être des
concurrence va être décidée l'année
prochaine eh bien on vous supprime tous
les vols intérieurs
par contre on vous autorise à faire
rouler des trains sur les lignes sur
lesquelles vous aviez des avions donc
vous avez qu'à faire quelques trains sur
paris-marseille quelques trains sur
paris toulouse etc et on supprime toutes
les lignes intérieures qui n'ont pas
lieu d'être
parce que on peut très bien le faire en
train voilà deux exemples
et comme de toute façon vous allez vous
prendre moins 10 ou -15 à -20%
d'activités pour les deux ans qui
viennent
bacon décide de supprimer ces trucs là
ça va pas priver d'activité de toute
façon parce que l'activité vous allez en
avoir moins dans tous les cas de figure
voilà voilà deux exemples on pourrait
réfléchir à d'autres est du reste on va
sortir notre liste de courses dans pas
très longtemps aussi project mais c'est
évident que c'est des contreparties qui
sont pas nécessairement très agréable à
entendre
par contre faire repartir air france à
l'identique dans le contexte pétroliers
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
n'offrent qu'une seule garantie c'est
que vous préparer la prochaine crise ça
n'offre pas du tout la garantie que air
france va se mettre à revivre comme un
banc pendant les vingt ans qui viennent
ça va être juste a garanti que dans les
dix ans qui viennent voir les cinq ans
qui viennent vous reprenez incomplète
sur le casque c'est absolument évident
je vous remercie on va maintenant partir
sur un secteur sur lequel vous vous
exprimez souvent acquis et le nucléaire
aujourd'hui edf prévoit une baisse qui
est assez significative de sa production
nucléaire en 2020 est ce qu'on peut déjà
prévoir les répercussions de cette
baisse de production
alors ça dépend si la question est une
question technique ou une question
économique
question si la question est
techniquement les réacteurs fonctionnent
un peu moins qui voit là il fonctionne
un peu moins c'est pas dire ça ne pose
pas de problème technique particulier ça
ne change pas la sûreté par contre tous
les électriciens et pas qu'edf à partir
du moment où ils ont des revenus qui
sont proportionnelles à leur production
vont souffrir
et encore une fois pas qu'edf c'est ça
concerne tous les électriciens européens
sauf les électriciens qui sont dans les
renouvelables pour une raison très
simple c'est que les renouvelables sont
payés par vos impôts miens et donc la
manière dont le système fonctionne en ce
qui concerne les renouvelables c'est
qu'on a dit aux gens qui ont installé
des éoliennes et des panneaux solaires
la collectivité vous garantit un prix
d'achat qui est de temps donc si le prix
de marché et en dessous du prix d'achat
garanti
on vous paye la différence et si le prix
de marché et au dessus vous avez droit
de vendre au prix de marché elle en
l'occurrence là il n'y a pas de au
dessus des prix de marché en france on
achète à tout le monde à un prix convenu
d'avancé panda il ya quelques années aux
très belles heures du solaire donc au
début du grenelle de l'environnement là
dans les années 2009-2010 le
mégawattheure solaire pouvait dans ces
contrats être vendu 500 euros avec un
prix de marché que aux alentours de 50
ça faisait des produits qu'ils avaient
un rendement sur capitaux investis qui
était de l'ordre de 15% a payé par les
impôts ce qui de mon point de vue était
un scandale absolu parce que quand on
vous le garantit vos revenus sur 20 ans
payé par le crapaud 15% c'est juste un
scandale mais c'est voilà il sarr a fait
quelques fortunes privées
quelques très belles fortunes privées
donc ces gens là aujourd'hui ne sont pas
concernées par la baisse des prix de
l'électricité ni par la baisse de la
consommation parce que ils sont
prioritaires sur le réseau donc on leur
dit c'est votre production comprend le
premier est par ailleurs comme ils ont
un prix garanti le prix continuent
d'être garantie donc même si le prix sur
le marché baisse et ils continuent à
être payés la même chose donc les
producteurs d'électricité renouvelable
sont des gens qui ne souffre absolument
pas par contre tous les autres qui
arrivent derrière
qu'ils soient du clae air à gaz ou à
charbon ou hydraulique 1 ça ne change
strictement rien de ce point de vue est
bien et eux ils vont moins vendre
puisque la société tourne au ralenti et
donc qu'on a besoin de moins
d'électricité
en ce moment vous avez une bonne partie
des usines qui tournent pas donc ses
usines ne consomme pas d'électricité
vous avez une partie des bureaux qui ne
fonctionne pas votre parti pour ces
bureaux ne conçoit pas d'électricité
une partie des transports qui fonctionne
pas donc ça vaut consomme moins
d'électricité et même si les gens sont
un peu plus chez eux et font un peu plus
la cuisson globalement il ya une baisse
de la consommation d'électricité dans le
pays qui se promène entre 15 et 20%
donc ça c'est suffisant pour que les
prix d'une partie de la production soit
vendu de manière baisse tout ce qui est
sur le marché en ce moment les prix de
marché se traîne à 20 euros du
mégawattheure à peu près la moitié du
prix de revient des déesses et c'est
également quelque chose qui va faire que
la consommation d'électricité va baisser
donc quel que soit le prix du
mégawattheure de toute façon on va en
vendre moins ça ça va poser un problème
encore une fois à tous les électriciens
dont qu'edf comme les autres et c'est
aussi quelque chose qu'ils n'avaient pas
été prévus dans le schéma de
fonctionnement du pays puisque à aucun
moment vous n'avez jamais vu passer un
scénario prévisionnel sur la
consommation électrique dans lequel on
vous a dit on suppose que le pib baisse
jamais quand vous regardez les
projections qui sont faites sur la
consommation électrique du bébé est
toujours en croissance
jusqu'à maintenant ça va peut-être
changer jusqu'à maintenant ç'a toujours
été qu'un bon je vous remercie
maintenant on le site et on va être dans
un contexte où les investissements va
être assez limité puisqu'il était à
débloquer des milliards pour sauver
notre économie et vous aider dans cette
situation a concrètement qu'est ce qu'il
va advenir de cette stratégie nationale
bas carbone qui avaient été mises en
place dans le gouvernement
alors là il est trop tôt pour moi avait
strictement aucune idée ce que je peux
vous dire c'est qu'au moment où la
stratégie nationale bas carbone a été
mise en place
elle était de toute façon c'était une
feuille de papier c'est à dire que au
moment où on décide pour de vrai de ce
qu'on fait pour de vrai c'est un truc
qui n'existe pas la stratégie nationale
bas carbone dit qu'il faut limiter les
déplacements il n'y a pas un maire qui a
arrêté de délivrer un permis de
construire
engendrant de l'étalement urbain au nom
de la slbc on a dit qu' il fallait
l'imiter alors un autre exemple on
s'apprêtait à faire le quatrième
terminal de roissy on va changer d'avis
mais on s'apprêtait quand même à le
faire et à ce moment là les engagements
pris sur le climat était totalement
oublié on a dit qu'on allait favoriser
la décarbonation du chauffage des
bâtiments en attendant au moment où on a
fait les diagnostics de performance
énergétique
on s'est débrouillé pour pénaliser
l'électricité en faveur du gaz
de telle sorte qu'une bonne partie des
red hot for pay notre parti mais une
partie des rénovations qui était fait
dans le journal dans le logement social
consistait justement à passer
d'électricité au gaz donc à augmenter
les émissions de co2 avec des
subventions publiques pour gagner deux
classes de diagnostic de performance
énergétique et à chaque fois qu'on avait
l'occasion d'installer en france avec
invest i de france une nouvelle
industrie qui consommaient du gaz du
charbon et on était ravi de le faire
donc
la snb c'est aujourd'hui c'est du beau
et du reste il ya une très bonne manière
de ne rien faire c'est de se fixer des
objectifs pour 2050 et surtout pas pour
l'année prochaine et en général c'est ça
qu'on a fait et dans ses objectifs
qu'est ce que vous pensez que les
banques publiques d'investissement par
exemple les banques centrales elles vont
jouer un rôle
après cette crise les banques centrales
ont une règle absolue jusqu'à maintenant
qui est celle de la neutralité de la
delà de l'utilisation de l'argent dit
autrement il ne peut pas y avoir une
utilisation sectorielle préférentiel de
l'argent qu'elles fournissent c'est
quelque chose qu'elle se sont interdits
c'est la raison pour laquelle à chaque
fois qu'on a poussé la bce à dire faites
donc un plan de relance vers la bce a
toujours dit moi je veux bien créer de
la monnaie mais y'a pas de raison que ce
soit mais c'est pas dans les statuts que
ce soit vers plutôt que - plutôt que
jaune rouge ou violet donc
la bce a toujours refusé de faire ça il
n'empêche que quand la bce fait de la
création monétaire
ça peut très bien être ensuite utilisée
pour alimenter ensuite les états et les
banques qui elles mêmes peuvent avoir
l'obligation de financer des choses qui
sont vertes
donc on pourrait très bien dire alors il
ya deux manières de faire ça on peut
obliger les banques où on peut obliger
les emprunteurs
si demain matin on dit à tous les
propriétaires à partir de maintenant
vous avez l'obligation de faire la
rénovation thermique de votre logement
c'est pas un truc qu'on vous demande si
c'est rentable pas rentable c'est
pourquoi c'est obligatoire les gens vont
le faire et si le fonds une partie
d'entre eux et éventuellement iront voir
leur banc en disant on va écouter vous
allez me faire un prêt et moi je vais
financer les travaux avec ce prêt puis
derrière j'ai voulu rembourser sur titan
de telle sorte que la mensualité de mon
prêt représente à peu près mes économies
d'énergie ou au moins avec les économies
d'énergie c'est un peu pas trop cher
donc vous pouvez avoir un phénomène
comme ça de répercussions en cascade qui
permet avec de l'argent qui est
initialement créée au sommet d'avoir des
projets qui sont eux considérés comme
maire
mais c'est pas quelque chose en général
que vous mettez au stade de la création
monétaire elle même qui allait d'autres
je vous remercie en tout cas pour ces
réponses
on va maintenant pouvoir passer à la
phase de questions-réponses justement où
les participants auront la parole donc
pour ceux qui ne l'auraient pas vu on a
un onglet donc question réponse juste en
bas de l'écran qui vous permet de poser
vos questions mais également de voter
pour les questions groupe g les plus
pertinentes à et qui sont donc posées à
monsieur j'ai accompli si donc la
première qui retire donc le plus de
votes 20 de vincent dupuy
que pensez-vous du revenu universel est
il viable dans un pays dès qu'ils se
contractent
on a déjà aujourd'hui une forme de
revenu universel même s'il porte pas ce
nom là
décomposée en sous-ensembles ce revenu
universel
une partie de ce sous ensemble c'est
l'allocation chômage pour les gens qui
ont perdu un emploi
une partie de ce revenu universel c'est
les minimums sociaux qui peuvent être
accordées à des gens qui n'ont jamais eu
d'activité où le minimum vieillesse qui
est accordé à des gens qui n'ont pas de
retraite ou une retraite ridicule donc
aujourd'hui le revenu universel alors il
n'est pas harmonisée c'est à dire que ce
qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui c'est tout
le monde a tant d'argent est exactement
la même somme mais par contre vous avez
déjà des mécanismes de solidarité qui
approche
même si ça n'est pas exactement ça cette
idée là c'est à dire que l'on font que
vous travaillez que vous travaillez pas
vous avez droit à quelque chose donc on
peut très bien même sans créer un revenu
universel discuter des plafonds et des
planchers qui sont applicables et les
catégories qui doivent en bénéficier
parce que par ailleurs moi il ya aucune
raison que je sois considère qu'elles
soient concernés par le revenu universel
en plus de ce que je gagne
alors après la question peut être de me
supprimer ce que je gagne actuellement
pour que j'aie un d'universel qui est
égal à celui de mon voisin mais ça c'est
plus exactement le même sujet à ce
moment vous rentrez dans un système qui
est un système totalement égalitariste
c'est à dire où on considère que quoi
que vous fassiez vous avez de toute
façon pas plus de valeur que quelqu'un
d'autre
et donc je discute et à ce moment vous
êtes vous avez dit la même chose
l'expérience montre que la nature
humaine étant ce qu'elle est et en
particulier notre envie féroce de
s'élever dans les groupes sociaux ça
marche pas bien quand on essaye de le
faire pour de vrai toujours en fait le
système se dit toujours avoir des effets
de bord et à ne pas ressembler à la
théorie voilà donc ce que j'en pense
c'est que c'est très bien accueilli et
des filets de sécurité
pour un certain nombre de gens parfaits
je fais partie des gens qui ne sont qui
pensent que c'est pas grave s'il ya
quelques profiteurs du système
j'ai connu dans ma vie des gens
ingénieurs cadres supérieurs partis à
l'étranger se déclarant au chômage en
france est touchant à la fois de chômage
en france il est revenu à l'étranger
pourraient trouver totalement scandaleux
j'ai pas tellement pas trouvé génial
mais c'est pas parce qu'il ya quelques
profiteurs du système qu'il faut
supprimer le système
donc je pense que c'est très bien qu'ils
aient ce genre de système que
contrairement à ce qu'on dit souvent les
gens qui sont concernés par ces revenus
là sont pas des gens qui sont ravis dont
profite et je pense qu'il préférerait
avoir un job et se sentir utile là où
ils sont pour leur immense majorité
et ça ne règle pas par ailleurs la
question le revenu universel du fait de
se sentir utile parce que les gens qui
ont un revenu mais pas d'activité sont
souvent des gens qui souffrent du fait
de ne pas avoir leur place dans la
société c'est à dire que personne n'ait
besoin de quelque part quand on a un
travail
quelque part il ya des gens qui ont
besoin de vous ça vous amuse est utile
vous avez vous avez un rôle dans
quelqu'un a besoin d'eux et le fait que
quelqu'un ait besoin de vous c'est
important donc le revenu universel est
pas totalement indissociable de la
question sur l'activité sinon une
question dans ce domaine transport
pendant pas moins de la plus élevée en
france selon votre expertise qu'elle
voit sont à privilégier dans ce domaine
quelles mesures pratiques seraient les
plus efficaces et enfin à quel point le
développement de technologies comme les
véhicules électriques et les véhicules
roulant à l'hydrogène peuvent permettre
la transition dans ce secteur alors
réponse en plusieurs temps le transport
est un domaine dans lequel vous avez
plusieurs types de déplacements qui
correspondent à des à des raisonnements
très différent des transports du
quotidien c'est à dire quand on n'est
pas confiné le fait d'aller travailler
d'aller faire ses courses d'avoir une
société sociale de proximité voir des
amis pourquoi
d'aller à l'école ou d'aller chercher
ses enfants c'est une logique qui est
une philosophie qui est totalement
différente des transport longue distance
qui sont essentiellement liés aux
loisirs et à des déplacements
professionnels
donc ça se traite pas de la même manière
on peut très bien imaginer de remplacer
une partie des déplacements longue
distance par de la visioconférence et du
télétravail c'est plus difficile de
remplacer le fait d'aller faire ses
courses par de la visioconférence et du
télétravail
vous pouvez vous faire livrer mais donc
le fait d'aller voir des amis quand on
n'est pas confiné c'est quand même un
truc c'est bon en ce moment il est à des
gens qui font des visions apéro mais je
pense qu'il pourrait faire un vrai
l'apéro il préférerait donc les marges
de manoeuvre les deux les possibilités
substitution sont pas les mêmes en
fonction du motif du déplacement
deuxième chose qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est que nous sommes des animaux et que
aussi loin que remontent les
statistiques nous sortons de chez nous
et en ce moment où on peut pas le faire
on sent bien qu'on a une gêne physique
pour un certain nombre d'entre nous en
moyenne trois fois par jour
or ce qui veut dire que ce sur quoi on
peut jouer c'est pas la suppression à la
baisse du nombre de déplacements de
toutes façons de sortir à trois fois par
jour de chez nous quand on peut pas et
quand on quand on peut pardonner quand
on ne peut pas s'appelle la prison et en
ce moment on est à mi chemin entre la
prison et voilà un certain de jean
le donc ce sur quoi on peut jouer si la
portée du déplacement et le mode
technique avec lequel on se déplace si
on veut décarbonés les transports on
peut donc jouer sur l'énergie qu'on
utilise pour propulser le véhicule qu'on
utilise donc à ce moment on reste avec
le même type de véhicule mais en charge
son énergie on garde une voiture l'a
fait passer à l'électricité à supposer
que l'électricité soit décarbonés donc
en france ça marche mais en pologne ça
marche moyen en pologne à une voiture
électrique et met à peu près autant de
co2 et de particules fines à cause de la
centrale à charbon qu'une voiture à
pétrole de bemba ces mêmes puissances
donc la voiture électrique ça ne marche
que si vous avez par ailleurs décarbonés
votre électricité qui renvoie à un autre
problème qui est ce qu'on va y arriver
les élites le vous pouvez après baisser
la quantité d'énergie nécessaire pour se
déplacer par exemple vous pouvez passer
d'une voiture un vélo à assistance
électrique
à ce moment vous utilisez beaucoup moins
d'énergie parce qu'une vieille règle de
physique vous dit que l'énergie pour se
déplacer est proportionnelle à la masse
il ya un devis de mv2 et donc si vous
prenez un engin qui a une masse beaucoup
plus faible vous allez avoir besoin
d'une énergie beaucoup plus faible pour
le déplacer et du reste une batterie de
vélos à assistance électrique ces
quelques centaines de watts une batterie
de voiture électrique c'est quelques
dizaines de kilowatts d'accord donc
c'est des centaines de fois plus
enfin c'est une centaine de fois plus
rien donc le donc la deuxième chose
qu'on peut faire c'est changer de type
de véhicule est une autre manière de
changer de type de véhicule c'est d'être
plusieurs dans un véhicule où on était
que tout seul ou de prendre des
véhicules où on est par construction
plusieurs les bus des trains etc
alors il faut jouer sur l'ensemble de
ces modes pour arriver à trouver un
optimum sachant que l'optimum correspond
économiquement ou plus faibles
investissements que vous pouvez faire
pour économiser une tonne de co2 alors
c'est ça le petit bob économique et ça
dépend de la situation de départ ce
n'est pas de cela si vous êtes en milieu
rural jamais on va vous mettre un rer
devant chaque porte donc à ce moment la
voiture électrique peut être une bonne
idée le vélo à assistance électrique
peut être une bonne idée et le
covoiturage peuvent être une bonne idée
le bus si on commence à être
suffisamment nombreux peut être une
bonne idée si vous êtes en interurbain
le train contre l'avion peut être une
bonne idée si vous êtes en banlieue
d'une grande ville la mutualisation des
déplacements le vélo et éventuellement
même du mode lourd peut être une bonne
idée donc ça dépend vraiment c'est
contextuel
on a fait aux chiffres d'un rapport sur
la mobilité périurbaines il ya quelques
mois que j'invite les gens à les lire et
justement explique la combinatoire qu'on
peut utiliser pour essayer de progresser
sur ce terrain là mais c'est un terrain
compliqué je remercie maintenant une
question dévasta aurès quelle est la
place des villes dans le monde d'après
le privilégier un étalement ou une
densification de notre territoire
alors il faut surtout privilégier les
petites villes lutèce faisait je crois
qu'elle qu'une dizaine de milliers de
feux à l'époque on appelait ça des feux
donc le test l'ancien parisien le paris
de la renaissance faisait je crois moins
de 100000 habitants donc à l'époque la
ville et est petit pourquoi est ce que
la ville était petit parce que la
première chose que vous avez besoin de
faire chaque jour c'est de manger et en
ville on ne sait pas pousser les
aliments qu'on consomme et pour pouvoir
nourrir une ville vous êtes donc
tributaire du disque qui entourent la
ville et plus exactement du surplus
agricoles dégagée par le disque qui
entourent la ville et où vous pouvez
transporter les denrées avant qu'elle de
sabine alors à l'époque où on transporte
les denrées avec des chars et table à
pied et éventuellement des carrioles à
cheval on va dire qu'avant que la
d'henri s'abîme allait il se passe 48
heures 72 heures et donc vous pouvez
nourrir la ville avec le surplus
agricoles dégagé par un disque qui
entourent la ville qui fait deux ou
trois jours de distance que vous pouvez
parcourir en charrette à cheval
et si le paysan a pas les moyens de se
payer l'auberge c'est même pas deux ou
trois jours c'est un jour donc vous
voyez ça ça vous donne une idée de la
quantité de nourriture qui peut être
dégagée pour nourrir les habitants de la
ville et vous pouvez pas faire vivre une
ville plus grosses que ça puisque sinon
les gens meurent de faim donc la
personne dans le vide
la raison pour laquelle la ville a
grossi au cours des 19ème et 20ème
siècles c'est parce que la portée et la
vitesse des déplacements ont
considérablement augmenté
et donc maintenant on peut faire venir
tous les jours dans paris grâce à son
ventre
viseo la maintenance était passé à
rungis
de quoi nourrir tous les franciliens
parce que si on devait nourrir les
franciliens en paris au sens large avec
juste ce qui pousse en ile de france
eh bien vous seriez depuis longtemps
famélique aux portes de faim mais moi
aussi dans la ville de là dans la ville
de là près on va avoir notamment moins
d'énergie abondante
on l'aura moins d'énergie abondante soit
parce qu'on veut juguler le changement
climatique et que l'essentiel de
l'énergie et fossiles etc on frappe à la
substitution ou vers le renouvelable et
nucléaire
un pour un la peau de vitesse ça
marchera pas ce n'est pas assez rapide
et si en plus on veut pas de nucléaire
on la fera encore moins vite nous
restera encore moins d'énergie à
l'arrivée et donc soit on veut lutter
contre le changement climatique et a
cependant on est obligé de faire
décroître très très vite la quantité
d'énergie fossile donc d'énergie taux
courts qu'on utilise et donc par exemple
la quantité de camions donc la quantité
de nourriture qui peut arriver tous les
jours un régis et ensuite nouvelle les
franciliens ou bien il suffit pas de
mettre tout ça sur des trains ça marche
pas vous pouvez pas mettre une station
de train devant chaque champ de blé et
chaque match et chaque chèvre chaque
fabricant chaque chant crise pour
arriver donc chaque fille ça marche
barça donc dans le monde de la presse
vous avez beaucoup moins d'énergie
vous aurez donc de toutes façons des
villes qui seront plus petit parce que
vous pouvez nourrir moins de monde
tassé au même endroit alors après
qu'elle soit dans souhaité aller c'est
presque un déterminant du deuxième ordre
le déterminant du premier ordre c'est
vraiment moins de monde en ville le la
deuxième chose c'est que tout le reste
de ce que vous utilisez en ville se
produit ailleurs les vêtements que vous
êtes en train de peut vous porter en ce
moment là la matière première qui les
constituent soit c'est du coton et ça a
poussé à des milliers de kilomètres
d'ici
soit c'est du lin hsin est riche je ne
vois pas la dc et à ce moment c'est un
peu poussé en france soit il ya des
fibres synthétiques lorsque vous portez
donc il ya un poli un peu de folie
quelque chose
et à ce moment vous porter un bout de
pétrole parce que toutes les fibres
synthétiques sont faites avec du pétrole
via la pétrochimie et le pétrole n'est
pas produit en france il va même produit
très loin et il a fait trois fois le
tour de la terre
entre le moment où il a été produit et
tous ces traitements intermédiaire donc
vous voyez bien que l'on peut pas non
plus avoir sur place dans la ville de
quoi habiller les gens avec les moutons
dont il serait la laine autant la tuerie
sur les toits des immeubles
ça marchait pas bien donc il faut
contracter la taille des villes dans le
monde de la presse le dernier point
c'est que ce qui est rentable
économiquement en ville c'est de gérer
des services et des services sont
essentiellement basées sur des fonctions
des changes
là en ce moment on est en train
d'échanger des informations bonne partie
des services consistent à échanger des
informations
une autre partie des services et la
vente ça échange des produits une autre
partie des services
c'est la finance ça échange de l'argent
donc en gros les services sont basées
sur des fonctions des changes et la
ville marche bien avec beaucoup de gens
qui s'occupent des échanges si vous avez
énormément de trucs à échanger et
énormément de trucs à échanger veut dire
une société dopé à l'énergie fabricant
énormément de produits et de services
qui permettent d'être échangé derrière
dans une société sobre en énergie et
regarder les sociétés agraires ans
ancien td société sobre en énergie qui
avait pas beaucoup de gens dans les
services donc dans une société sobre en
énergie vous aurez pas besoin de tous
ses services
donc vous mettrez une partie des gens au
chômage dans les grandes villes et en
plus vous aurez plus qu à les faire
manger
donc il faut absolument dégonfler les
villes et c'est ça qui va être le
chantier majeur il est totalement en
versant au sens propre du terme puisque
de ces derniers siècles on a eu à
baliser le monde est en ce moment les
pays émergents sont en train de
s'urbaniser à toute vitesse
malheureusement c'est une évolution qui
n'est pas durable dans un monde qui va
avoir une évolution énergétique qui va
se renverser et c'est évidemment un
redoutable défi parce que pour changer
une ville vous faites pas ça en une
semaine
en gros chantier en perspective un de
plus en plus une question maintenant de
une marque en la personne
êtes vous optimiste ou pessimiste quant
à la capacité de l'union européenne de
préparer un plan de relance allant dans
le bon sens alors sur cette question
précise je suis extrêmement pessimiste
je pense que l'europe doit se
reconstruire en dehors de l'europe quand
l'europe a été construite l'europe a été
construite non pas autour d'instruments
de marché d'à quoi l'europe a été
construite autour d'un projet très
simple qui était vivre en paix vous vous
rappelez probablement que les
fondamentaux de l'europe ont été jetés
quasiment dès le lendemain de la seconde
guerre mondiale avec comme comme light
motif le plus jamais ça est une des
raisons pour lesquelles les français et
les allemands se sont écharpés à n'en
plus finir
c'était notamment pour accéder aux
ressources de minerai de fer et de
charbon qui sont situés sur toute la
bande qui va de la belgique à l'alsace
en passant par l'art au nord et la
lorraine au sud et la rive donc la
manière dont on s'est dit qu'on allait
arrêter de se battre c'est qu'on allait
mettre en commun les ressources
essentielles et une fois que les
ressources essentielles sont en commun
et parfois normalement on arrête de se
battre puisqu'elles sont pas tout le
monde et donc personne alors on a
commencé à faire ça avec le charbon et
l'acier ça a été la communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier
ça s'est prolongée derrière avec une
autre énergie qui est des descentes
quitté l'énergie atomique donc on a fait
auratum et derrière on a fait l'union
européenne et l'union européenne
n'avaient pas à l'époque pour but de
faire un marché de faire ce pour quoi
elle avait pour but de faire la paix et
puis au fur et à mesure que le pardon
est alors pour faire la paix se sont dit
les fondateurs de l'europe
il faut que les gens aient la ressource
principale en commun qui par ailleurs il
faut qu'ils se connaissent parce que
quand on se connaît bien on n'a pas
envie de se taper dessus quand on
connaît bien les gens en général il y en
a une bonne partie ils font quelques
efforts pour paraître sympathique voilà
et donc on se tape moins dessus et pour
favoriser la connaissance entre les
peuples il faut favoriser les échanges
et pour favoriser les échanges on sait
dire leur favoriser le commerce c'est
une bonne manière de favoriser les
échanges
donc on va supprimer à l'intérieur de
l'europe de manière progressive
tout ce qui est une entrave à la liberté
du commerce
il de là on a dévoyé le projet c'est à
dire que ce qui était le moyen est
devenu le but est aujourd'hui l'europe
plus personne ne vous dit que c'est une
façon de vivre en paix et tout le monde
vous dit que c'est pour faire un marché
on s'en fout du marché c'est-à-dire le
marché est un objet c'est un instrument
est ici trop de marché et tu le projet
de paix et bien on fait moins de marchés
moyen c'est pas du tout une fin en soi
sauf que à force de dire c'est ça qu'on
va faire du coup on en a mis absolument
partout à toutes les sauces et le marché
et la libre concurrence sont
antinomiques de la politique
industrielle et de la planification
à partir du moment où vous faites de la
politique industrielle et de la
planification c'est vous dites je vais
faire ça et passa donc les gens qui
veulent faire des petites bagnoles j'ai
autorisé à exercer ce qu'il veut faire
des grosses bagnoles non je vais
favoriser tel acteur qui sait faire de
petites bagnoles et pas telle autre qui
c'est pour faire des petits pagnol jeu
et c'est donc à partir du moment où vous
faites de la politique industrielle
vous rentrez par construction dans un
système dans lequel vous n'êtes plus sur
un pied d'égalité en ce qui concerne
tous les gens qui voudraient rentrer
dans l'univers concurrentiel
donc ça irrite au plus haut point
l'institution européenne et tous les
fonctionnaires de la commission qui
passent leur temps à tirer à vue sur
tout ce qui peut ressembler à quelque
chose qui n'est pas libre marché en
croyant que c'est ça qui va faire le
bonheur des peuples alors c'est un
système soit dit en passant qui marche
très bien dans un univers en croissance
parce que dans un univers en croissance
finalement l'abondance vous est donnée
de droit et le marché il vous sert à
gérer les fluctuations marginal de
manière optimale donc ça va très très
bien mais dans un univers contraint le
marché ça ne marche pas vous n'avez
jamais vu un général à la guerre dire
voilà je vais faire un appel d'offres en
respectant la concurrence pour savoir
quatre sections je vais envoyer
reprendre le beats audio qui est la
barre vraiment ça que vous voyez
et au moment où les pays sont passés par
des épisodes très contraint ce qui a été
le cas d'un totalité des pays jusqu'au
moment où les combustibles fossiles vous
ont fait apparaître la libération par
les machines
vous n'aviez pas de libre concurrence
partout et tout le temps en france vous
alliez des charges qui était héréditaire
qui était enfin vous aviez des rentes
c'est tout était protégé alors je pense
à dire les rendent c'est formidable je
suis juste en train de vous dire le
système
je n'en sais rien plus tôt mais le
système qui était des fois c'est pas si
idiot mais le système qui est qui
existait à cette époque-là cdd système
pas du tout il vraiment concurrentiel
mais soit régalien soin de rendre
encadré donc le système librement
concurrentiel marche très bien dans un
univers en croissance dans un univers en
contraction c'est une machine à détruire
du capital donc je ne suis pas de hors
jeu ne crois pas du tout exactement
comme je disais tout à l'heure je ne
pense pas que le plan de relance va se
décider le plan de relance décarbonés va
se décider dans l'urgence ils n'étaient
pas prêts avant il sera pas prêt au
moins deux ans absolument c'est ce qu'on
s'est dit tout à l'heure
eh bien là c'est exactement pareil
la relance décarbonés au niveau européen
sera pas plus prête dans l'urgence
qu'elles étaient prêtes avant l'urgence
alors avant l'urgence aider quoi la
relance décarbonés et à la sauce
européenne s'était on va faire des
voitures électriques et des éoliennes et
tout va se passer comme par miracle et
de l'hydrogène
tout va bien aller c'est pas la peine de
s'occuper de la taille de l'île comme je
viens de l'évoquer c'est pas la peine de
s'occuper de la structure de notre
production agricole
c'est pas la peine de s'occuper de
brider les moyens de déplacement des
gens tout ça c'est inutile qu'on va
faire des voitures électriques et à
hydrogène et des avions à hydrogène
le seul petit inconvénient c'est que
tous ces moyens très hautement
technologiques sont très consommateurs
en capitaux et donc ils sont totalement
inenvisageable dans un monde en
contraction
vous aurez juste j'avais les moyens de
déployer ce genre de trucs j'avais
dans un monde en contraction il faut
faire ce que les ingénieurs appel du low
tech
c'est à dire de l'optimisation fine de
ce que vous savez déjà faire
ce que leurs hôtes ses objectifs clairs
une croissance qui soit décarbonés dont
elle sait pas ce que parce que nous
n'allons pas avoir la croissance et
l'europe sans croissance est tellement
perdu enfin est perdu elle est hyper du
notamment parce que je vous rappelle si
vous n'avez pas appris ça en cours de
politique européenne que la croissance
est explicitement mentionnée comme étant
un objectif européen dans l'article 3 du
traité de lisbonne
donc la croissance est un objectif
européen
je crois que c'est une des rares
constitution au monde dans lesquels on
dit la croissance est un objectif du
pays
on a passé dans la constitution
française par exemple on va maintenant
passer à une question des liasses le
petit emmanuel macron a annoncé une
relocalisation de l'industrie de la
culture en france
cela ne risque pas d'avoir pour effet
d'augmenter les gaz à effet serre c'est
une question sur la localisation et
nationales et non pas européenne alors
la réponse ici mais c'est pas
nécessairement une mauvaise affaire
si vous raisonnez en ce qui concerne
pardon il ya deux manières de raisonner
en ce qui concerne les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre des français vous
pouvez vous occuper de ce qu'il ya lieu
sur le territoire national et vous
pouvez vous occuper de ce qu'on appelle
l'empreinte carbone c'est à dire toutes
les émissions qui sont la conséquence de
tout ce qu'on consomme
je reviens à la chemise que vous portez
elle n'a pas été fabriqué en france
pourtant vous vous en servez en france
enfin à moins que vous soyez en ce
moment confinées je ne sais pas où vous
îles vanuatu
vous êtes en france donc les émissions
qui sont la contrepartie de votre
chemise
vous en profiter par contre elle ne sont
pas dans l'inventaire national ne sont
pas dans l'inventaire des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre en france
si je décide de rapatrier en france les
usines qui fait votre chemise
je vais évidemment augmenter les
émissions françaises puisque ces
émissions qui avant avait lieu au
bangladesh ou en thaïlande vont
maintenant avoir lieu en france
mais si lusinchi meuf qui fait votre
chemise en france est plus efficace que
l' usine de thaïlande ou du bangladesh
parce que par exemple elle utilise de
l'électricité décarbonée parce que je me
débrouille parce que j'ai demandé à mes
ingénieurs de faire des processus qui
sont plus efficaces que ceux que j'avais
avant etc
et bien je peux à la fois à voir
augmenter les émissions françaises est
globalement en fait une bonne affaire
sur votre empreinte carbone
donc le fait qu'on relocalise des
activités en france peut très bien être
une bonne affaire pour le climat tout
étant effectivement facialement une très
mauvaise affaire pour les émissions
domestiques
or il se trouve que dans le cadre des
accords internationaux les pays stipule
pour eux mêmes donc le seul engagement
qu'ils ont c'est sur leurs émissions
domestiques
donc le fait de relocaliser des
activités va effectivement on peut dire
heurter les engagements que nous avons
pris sur la neutralité carbone en france
qui est un engagement qu'on aurait mieux
fait de prendre sur l'empreinte carbone
alors évidemment il était beaucoup plus
de chalets de gens si on l'avait pris
sur l'empreinte carbone par contre là
pour le coup on aurait pu joindre
l'utile à l'agréable c'est à dire que la
relocalisation en france d'un certain
nombre d'activités aurait été de pair
avec une baisse possible de l'empreinte
carbone sur les métaux qu'on utilise par
exemple l'aluminium qu'on utilise pour
faire de l'aluminium faut utiliser
énormément d'électricité entre une
fonderie d'aluminium utilisé en
australie une fonderie d'aluminium
utilisés en france vous avez carrément
est quasiment part dans une baisse d'un
facteur 10 sur les émissions par tonne
donc là voilà typiquement une drôle
localisation industrielle dans laquelle
on gagne des émissions audio global
en plein de questions de noix fleischel
vous avez participé à la convention
citoyenne pour le climat pensez vous que
cela peut vraiment donner un élan au
gouvernement pour lancer la transition
carbone je n'ai pas la réponse alors moi
je n'ai pas été membre de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat j'ai simplement
été auditionné comme on dit un jour mais
si vous regardez la vidéo de l'audition
j'ai dû parler un quart d'heure parce
qu'on était quatre sur le plateau est-ce
que macron va écouter la convention
citoyenne pour le climat je n'en sais
strictement rien ce que je sais c'est
que au moment où cette convention a été
lancée on était par beau temps la mairie
dit calme quelques petites vagues lect
et macron s'est dit voilà je vais lancer
cet ovni m'engager à écouter ce qu'ils
me racontent alors au début il s'était
engagé à en faire un projet de loi après
je crois qu'ils s'étaient seulement
engagées à écouter ce qu'ils racontaient
enfin pourquoi il se rapporte
et comme c'est un comme tous les gens
qui occupent ce genre de poste un
virtuose de la politique
eh bien c'est dit je vais lancer ce truc
là et je trouverai bien le moment venu
le moyen de le retourner à mon avantage
pour de bonnes ou de mauvaises raisons
peu importe si terre qui peuvent
retourner à son avantage parce que les
coupes les propositions sont vraiment
pertinente qui va vraiment les mettre en
oeuvre tout le monde dira bravo bravo ou
le retourner à son avantage en noyant le
poisson parce que les trucs du ps pas du
tout tout en ayant l'impression d'avoir
écouté le bon peuple
voilà donc alors je ne sais absolument
pas ce qu'il avait en tête une idée je
ne sais surtout parce qu'il part en
faire dans le contexte actuel parce que
maintenant que les galgos vide qui est
passée par là d'abord vous avez un
certain nombre de gens qui vous disent
aujourd'hui ça va bien les contraintes
environnementales mais on verra ça plus
tard notamment air france pour en
revenir à ce que ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure le patron d'air france a dit bon
il ya un certain nombre de taxes là si
on pouvait y a repoussé de deux ans ça
m'arrangerait bien un skill à être fait
probablement donc le
donc ce que la sortir de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat dans le
contexte actuel et au moment où ça
sortira pas ce que ça va probablement
pas sortir avant septembre
je n'ai pas la moindre idée de ce que
macro en francs tout ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que j'ai noté dans le disque
dans le dernier discours qu'il a fait
qu'il a parlé de sobriété carbone et de
planification avec une virgule entre les
deux qui restent c'est dommage il aurait
mieux fait pas m 2,1 entre les deux je
n'ai pas la moindre idée de ce à quoi ça
correspond
on peut tout imaginer on peut imaginer
que il a été frappé par la grâce et
qu'il a tout compris
ça me paraît peu probable on peut
l'imaginer on peut imaginer que un de
ses conseillers lui a dit vous devriez
en parler regardez ce que ça donne comme
réaction lancé moi donc ce ballon
d'essai à mon avis c'est ça qui sait et
donc il se dit ben on voit je vais voir
si un certain nombre de gens me dire que
c'est vachement bien ce que tu as dis là
c'est très bien très bonne idée et si
effectivement il ya un nombre croissant
de gens qui lui disent ça à ce moment il
passera à l'étape 2 qui est de commencer
à faire travailler des gens sur la
question ou à ouvrir ses oreilles pour
des gens qui ont déjà travaillé sur la
question et qu'ils ont d'être concret à
proposer dont éventuellement les gens de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
pour ce que j'ai vu de leurs
propositions la convention citoyenne
pour le climat ça reste des orientations
générales gens quand ils disent il faut
augmenter fortement la rénovation des
bâtiments et la rendre obligatoire
c'est une bonne idée donc moi je suis
pour que ce soit obligatoire mais on
n'est pas encore allé jusqu'au bout du
raisonnement si on vend la rénovation
obligatoire vous avez 30 millions de
logements en france si on veut les
rénover sur 30 ans a fait un million par
an alors au début ce sera moi ça sera
plus compte tenu du nombre de personnes
qu'il faut pour rénover un logement
ça veut dire en gros faire entrer deux
ou trois cent mille personnes dans
l'artisanat du bâtiment
donc ça veut dire que vous de vous dire
allez à sciences po parce que c'est
vachement bien ou didot des pompiers
parce que c'est vachement bien voilà
c'est ça que ça veut dire en pratique
d'accord c'est à dire que vos
instituteur vous dit ça quand vous êtes
gamin
donc il ya encore un peu de chemin à
parcourir pour qu'on y arrive non pas de
plombier ce soit un métier honteux mais
c'est juste qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas du
tout discours de l'éducation nationale
et donc il n'y a pas que a changé le
fait que ce soit obligatoire pour les
propriétaires il ya aussi tout un tas
d'autres trucs à changer dans la
formation dans la confiance qui peut y
avoir avec les gens qui font dans les
mécanismes économiques qui permettent
que ce soit fait et c est donc quand la
convention citoyenne dit il faut le
rendre obligatoire c'est pas fini comme
proposition et enfin dernier point si
vous le fait pas qu'est ce que vous
risquez est ce que vous risquez
l'interdiction de vendre votre logement
est ce que vous risquez une
multiplication par quatre des impôts
fonciers enfin qu'est ce que vous
risquez donc il faut finir deux décliné
cette proposition donc la seule chose
qui est intéressant enfin la seule chose
la chose qui est intéressant dans cette
convention c'est qu'elles émanent du
terrain donc ça c'est très intéressant
ça montre qu'une fois que les gens ont
pris un grand coup sur la cafetière
parce que c'est ce qui leur est arrivé
au début en découvrant l'ampleur du
problème
ils sont capables d'avoir des
propositions qu'on coupait disruptive
que ce qu'on serait capable d'accepter
en temps normal l'épisode actuel soit
dit en passant nous montre qu'on est
capable d'avoir des comportements très
descriptif très vite à partir du moment
où il ya une volonté nationale qu'il en
soit ainsi
alors moi je regrette que ce soit pour
les vieux dont je fais partie mais pas
pour les jeunes mais après c'est un
autre débat mais puisque je pense qu'on
met un peu les priorités à l'envers mais
ça montre que quand on veut on peut quoi
je veux dire la convention nationale
dans cette affaire ans aux citoyennes
pardon elle a cet avantage de d'enfoncer
le clou dans un certain nombre de
directions
il y avait déjà des gens qui avait dit
ça très intéressant de le faire ne va
pas et c'est normal on peut pas lui
demander ça en sept week end jusqu'au
bout du chemin de la totalité des
propositions qui sont faites
et pour finir je ne sais pas quelle
place ça jouera dans ce que bacon fera
dans six mois et on peut imaginer
n'importe quoi entre il prend une
personne de cette convention pour la
nommer ministre jusqu'à il s'assied
dessus je n'en ai strictement aucune
question de l'idiot valentin qui rejoint
un peu cette idée de passer à une vision
plus sur le terrain vous et d'autres
pensent
l'après tels que gaël giraud ou arthur
keller peuvent-ils avoir un poids dans
les élections de 2002 au vu de l'écho
que les théories collapse hologue en
france une offre politique entre
parenthèses à partisane ne vous parle
est elle capable d'émerger de participer
à ces élections
je ne crois pas qu'il existe une offre
politique à partisane parce qu'à partir
du moment où vous créez une offre vous
êtes partisan
vous êtes partisan de votre offre alors
ce que ce que s'extasier débat la
question des parties déjà c'est un truc
qui ont précédé de gaulle donc le il ya
un certain nombre de républicains donc
je ne crois pas qu'on fasse un truc à
partisans du reste de gaulle a fini par
faire son parti je crois que ce qu'on
peut imaginer séculière partie des gens
qui veulent que on structure la vie
socioéconomique du pays autour d'un
objectif qu'ils soient sociétale et non
pas économique
dit autrement on renverse la hiérarchie
entre l'économie et la société
et si en ayant bien compris ce que ça
veut dire pour faire société d'une autre
manière
on est prêts à consommer moins et à ce
que l'économie se contracte et c'est
bien ça qu'on a compris on sait comment
s'organiser en pareil car il sait nous
va bien ça devient quelque chose qui est
une proposition politique qui peut très
bien enfin je veux dire on possible de
gouverner un pays dans lequel les gens
sont d'accord avec les contreparties
ça fait longtemps que je pense que la
vraie rupture dans le monde politique
doit se faire entre ceux qui croient aux
comptes chili et ceux qui n'y croient
pas mais là je pense qu'on commence à y
être
donc moi ça devait dix ou quinze ans que
le disait ça mais comme tous les vieux
schnock du radote mais maintenant là je
pense qu'on y arrive et que c'est
vraiment le début de sa va se
cristalliser d'autant plus après
l'épisode qu'on est en train de vie donc
c'est ce que parce que la contraction on
va la connaître pendant un moment donc à
passer en année dans le monde
gaël giraud je ne sais pas s'il serait
mon personnage politique je ne prends
pas l'école absolue que caen avec cette
étiquette je ne crois pas non plus je
pense pas que pablo servi et envie de
devenir ministre
personnellement ça ne m'intéresse pas
c'est pas c'est pas je ne prends pas
être utile dans ce genre dans ce genre
de poste et de toute façon c'est un
cetain comment dire c'est une vision
présidentielle de ce dont on est en
train de parler c'est pas une vision
ministériel un ministre vous avez
s'occupe de petites choses comme le
disait le data donc le la question c'est
est ce qu'on peut voir émerger une offre
politique portée par quelqu'un de
crédible
avec un peu de stature qui soit orientée
autour d'une vision de la société dans
laquelle on donne pas la primauté à
l'économie et qu'ils aient la capacité
de comprendre d'expliciter et de faire
accepter toutes les contreparties qui
vont avec
et tout ça pour 2022 la réponse c'est
que si on s'y met pas maintenant il n'y
a aucune chance que maintenant c'est
déjà bien tard et que très honnêtement
je ne sais pas trop où sont les gens qui
pourraient correspondre à ce portrait
robot
il ya quelques personnes qui essayent de
se positionner un peu sur ce genre de
terrain mais ça suppose un certain
nombre de pré requis alors dans les
prérequis que ça suppose le premier
c'est de ne pas se mettre en porte à
faux avec les faits or dans le monde
politique que nous avons aujourd'hui
issus de deux siècles de croissance
tout le monde pense avec peu
d'exceptions que la technique
qu'en dire que le politique s'impose à
la technique
dit autrement le politique a décidé
confrères une autoroute dans ôté
faisable le politique a décidé qu'on
construira une maison la maison et
constructive le politique a décidé
congrès sur la lune on va sur la lune et
donc le technicien il n'est pas là pour
dire une seule politique le monde est
finie je peux pas faire ça il est là
pour dire oui monsieur windham et quand
on vous demande quelque chose de le
faire il se trouve que depuis les
premiers chocs pétroliers c'est devenu
un peu moins facile de raisonner comme
ça
et depuis le deuxième choc pétrolier
c'est-à-dire 2005 2008 c'est devenu
carrément impossible c'est à dire qu'il
ya plein de ministres qui voudraient
revenir la croissance fasse aussi faire
cela et puis en dessous ça marche pas
quoi donc bien les gens deviennent
neurasthénique wissant et le fait de
retrouver une forme de confiance avec la
technostructure et avec la compétence
technique est un prérequis absolument
indispensable à ce qu'un tel projet de
société fonctionne et dans les temps
anciens quand la société était très
contrainte le roi c'est à dire le
despote de l'époque qui était parce que
vous n'aviez que des despotes pour gérer
les sociétés contrainte seule entorse à
la sphère la démocratie athénienne et
romaine n'était pas des vraies
démocraties ça concernait une poignée de
citoyens ainsi sur les armes et
d'esclaves
donc on peut pas dire que ce soit
vraiment un système démocratique large
et bien le despote avait toujours près
de lui
des experts techniques de très haut
niveau qui était et les scientifiques
étaient toujours des gens qui
appartenait à la noblesse
d'abord il fallait avoir le temps de se
former c'est clair quand on était
couchés sur son champ de patates toute
la journée c'était plus compliqué de
théoriser la chute de la patate mais
mais mais le roi s'entourait à l'époque
des meilleurs experts et des meilleurs
des meilleurs compétences techniques de
son temps et au moment de la
constituante du reste en france vous
aviez tous les grands scientifiques de
l'époque qui était dedans donc le je ne
crois pas à la faisabilité d'un tel
programme dans un monde dans lequel le
lien de confiance entre les expertises
techniques et le politique continue à
être aussi d'élite et qu'il l'est
aujourd'hui
je crois que ça ne marche pas dans un
monde dans lequel vous n'êtes pas
capable de faire la pédagogie du
problème ce qui renvoie au problème
précédent
il m'a bien fait rigoler macron avec son
conseil scientifique sur le sur le
collier de là parce que la première
chose qu'il aurait dû faire après avoir
reçu greta tout bergues
c'était exactement la même chose sur les
problèmes d'énergie et de quillan
premier truc qu'il aurait dû faire on
attend toujours
donc ça ça suppose d'être capable de
faire la pédagogie du problème bah tout
très petit modeste expérience et quand
on explique aux gens pourquoi on a un
vrai problème est que ça va pas
nécessairement être simple vous faites
pas toujours sortir à grand coup de pied
dans le derrière et les gens acceptent
de discuter du partage de l'effort
le meilleur moyen pour que les gens
acceptent pas de discuter du partage de
l'effort c'est qu'ils aient l'impression
qu'on leur raconte des carabistouilles
donc ça ne marche pas si on n'est pas
capable de faire la pédagogie du
problème ça ne marche pas si on ne
retrouve pas le lien de le lien de
confiance avec les psp des expertises
techniques et la technostructure et ça
ne marche pas si on n'a pas pensé
longtemps à l'avancé tout un tas de
trucs sur lequel aujourd'hui le capital
intellectuel si l'ensemble guide et pour
reprendre un exemple que j'ai longuement
développé dans mon facebook l'aï dit
hier toute la question de comment on
fait fonctionner une société en
décroissance aujourd'hui est totalement
vierge dans le domaine économique
dans une société en décroissance par
exemple si on est toujours aussi
nombreux à votre mort au moment où vous
commencez à travailler
et bien non seulement vous gagnerez pas
de plus en plus d'argent à mesure que
vous vieillirez mes besoins gagnant est
de moins en moins comment je gère ça
d'accord y'a pas à d'économistes
aujourd'hui qui s'est penché sur la
question est-ce que ça va vous rendre
misérable malheureuse avec ses os enfin
voilà il n'ya pas il n'y a pas une
personne qui s'est penché sur la
question
donc deux ans pour se pencher sur cette
question s'est pas beaucoup
même quelqu'un comme gaël que j'adore je
ne crois pas qu'ils aient travaillé
pratiquement cette question là voilà
tout donc donc beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à et si je veux commencer à faire
dégonfler les villes comment je fais en
pratique comment est ce que je crée de
l'activité là où il y en a pas enfin
voilà donc c'est c1
c'est un ensemble très très compliqué
aujourd'hui les collabos log pour finir
répondre à la question non pas à ma
connaissance l'envi de travailler sur
les côtés pratiques de la faire
pour autant que je sache je leur pose
pas la question tous les jours mais je
ne crois pas il y en a un qui avait un
peu envie de travailler sur le côté
pratique de la question qu'il a fait
pour lui-même mais qui a un peu rangé
des voitures maintenant c'est yves
cochet voilà qui a il s'est mis une
maison en bretagne avec des panneaux
solaires
deux hectares quoi puis il a travaillé
le truc de manière un peu pratique mais
il n'a pas qu'il n'a pas mais pour
lui-même il n'a pas réfléchi à
l'organisation pratique de la société en
pareil cas mais je pense que c'est un
truc il gratter un peu quand même
sur la fin de sa carrière on sentait que
c'était un truc qui me gratter mais ils
sont rares les gens qui sont comme ça il
y en a marre en pratique pas je remercie
enfin j'avais une dernière question on a
pu parler de pas mal de thématiques
est ce que vous auriez justement une
lecture un documentaire ou un podcast à
lui conseillé pour aller un peu plus
loin
ça dépend ce que vous appelez à aller un
peu plus loin s'il s'agit de comprendre
le problème à traiter donc à la fois le
problème de la delà de l'interaction
entre le fonctionnement actuel de la
société et l'énergie et la question du
changement climatique qui est ma
deuxième spécialité j'ai envie de dire
après l'énergie donc je connais mal la
question de la biodiversité enfin elle
m'intéresse mais je veux dire je me
qualifie pas du tout d'experts je
connais un peu la question de la des
ressources minérales les ressources
métallique qui sont aussi nécessaires
actuellement notre activité mais j'en
suis pas un grand expert mais sur les
deux sujets que je viens d'évoquer donc
énergie et changement climatique
ce que je peux proposer de mieux pour la
population étudiante qui nous écoutent
c'est les vidéos de mon cours aux mines
qui sont librement accessibles sur
internet et les supports sont
accessibles en général il faut aller
dans les commentaires juste en dessous
de la vidéo sur youtube et il ya un
endroit où on peut la télécharger
vous avez des versions condensées de
secours sous forme de diverses
conférences à droite et à gauche dont
une que j'ai fait à sciences po à la
rentrée la dernière entrée en septembre
dernier une conférence inaugurale en
matière de livres vous avez peu de
livres qui sont très synthétique là
dessus j'ai envie de dire je suis désolé
de pda du groupe pour ma paroisse si je
vais quand même vous en sortez quelques
autres que le bien sûr sur l'imbrication
du fonctionnement de la société de
l'énergie les les quelques livres que
j'ai écrits seul ou en collaboration
avec d'autres auteurs sont des preuves
constitué des votes base partir du plus
récent le dernier c'est dormez
tranquilles jusqu'en 2100 l'avant
dernier c'était transition énergétique
pour tous celui d' encore avant
s'appelle c'est maintenant le sous titre
qui est trois ans pour sauver le monde
et c'était écrit en 2009
combien pas sauvé donc on va commencer à
souffrir un peu
et puis encore avant on avait écrit avec
alain grandjean le plein s'il vous plaît
dans lequel on avait déjà commencé à
décortiquer à sa pomme de mécanismes
dont qu il vaut mieux les lire dans
l'ordre dans lequel je viens d'évoquer
passe comme ça on parle du plus récent
il ya un livre absolument remarquable
sur le pétrole qui s'appelle or noir de
matthieu auzanneau qui par ailleurs le
directeur du chiffre qui est une somme
qui fait 600 pages qui est un livre qui
devrait beaucoup intéresser les
étudiants de sciences po parce que c'est
toute la géopolitique revisité par le
pétrole
c'est absolument passionnant c'est toute
la construction des états unis revisité
par le pétrole donc c'est un livre qui
du point de vue historique par rapport à
ce que j'ai pu écrire moi offre une
perspective qui est ici comme un robin
qui est vraiment très agréable à lire
après vous avez tout un tas d ouvrage du
technique donc qui sont peut-être moins
intéressant dans un
dans un premier temps vous avez quelques
vidéos de vulgarisation sur youtube qui
sont pas inintéressantes et un homme
s'appelle le réveil heures qui fait des
vidéos de vulgarisation vous avez ainsi
s'appelle connaissance des énergies qui
est pas mal qui fait la vulgarisation
aussi alors le mien comment s'adapter
donc je vais pas vous le recommander
vraiment moi maintenant je fais puisque
les choses récentes que je fais c'est
plus des articles des chroniques des
points de vue et des trucs comme ça là
effectivement vous avez sur mon site
perso
la production des mois écoulés et puis
bien évidemment vous avez les après tout
un tas de gens qui font des réflexions
des notes de synthèse au chapitre
desquels vous avez 44 qui fournit des
analyses de temps en temps avec des
angles qui sont un peu technique
c'est très orientée business ou bien le
chiffre project qui fournit des choses
qui sont plus sociétale voilà qui
peuvent être intéressantes également
je remercie je pense qu'on a de la cipa
dans les podcasts humeur vous pouvez
utiliser aussi écouter le présage
c'est le podcast d'alexia soyeux l'inde
- voilà qui est un très bon podcasts et
kieran angle plus psychologique donc
très complémentaires aussi de ce que je
viens de ce que je viens d'évoquer
et bien je vous remercie en tout cas je
pense qu'on va pouvoir clôturer ces
troisième épisode j'espère en tout cas
qu'il aura permis aux participants de
mieux appréhender la situation actuelle
et surtout l'impact d'un point de vue
énergétique
je vous remercie monsieur jancovici
d'avoir bien voulu participer et d'avoir
contribué à penser le monde après on va
pouvoir se retrouver la semaine
prochaine avec d'autres intervenants que
je vais dévoiler tout au long du
week-end dans tout cas merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé et voilà d'avoir
contribué à ce projet vous souhaite un
excellent week-end et je vous dis à
bientôt dans vos pensées d'après